So, what is X-Factor? In this tiny
presentation, I'm going to break down
what made Dolly Parton a superstar and
we can learn from her in making your own
content and impact on the world. So,
let's zoom out. In a world of infinite
content, in this world of AI, how do you
actually stand out when anyone can make
lots of stuff with a click of a button?
In a single word, it's quality, right?
But quality has two components to it.
There's a message and then there's the
messenger.
Uh and the two are inextricably linked.
So, you know, you could have a Trump or
a Bernie Sanders or a Dolly Parton and
they could say a super boring random
thing and still get millions of views.
How? In that case, solely because of the
messenger.
In a different situation, you could have
a no-name account go completely viral
and in that situation, would it be the
messenger or the message? It's the
message. And so, it's both of these
things together which create the entire
package. And so, there's a lot of stuff
on message and the the nature of content
out there, but there's very little
tactical stuff on the messenger. How
does the messenger themselves have
X-Factor? How are they more interesting?
It's one of the most common things that
I hear people use when describing
someone who becomes popular, aka they
garner interest above average,
uh is something called X-Factor, right?
And so, in different terms, it's used um
je ne sais quoi, which is like a French
word which literally just means I don't
know what. But the thing is is that
there has to be something, otherwise you
wouldn't recognize it. But it's
interesting that across different
languages, it's X, it's literally a
variable that could be anything. Or in
French, it's I don't know what it is. Um
but if we can recognize it, means
there's a pattern, right? And it's just
that our ability to recognize the
pattern surpasses our ability to
translate into the language. All right,
so my goal here is to translate X-Factor
from I don't know what into I know what,
to the best of my very limited ability.
And so, since many of you are making
content and ads and putting yourself out
there, um let's start by defining
X-Factor, right? So, X-Factor is when a
person captures outsized interest by
demonstrating multiple rare skills and
or physical traits that do not typically
coexist. And the more rarities they
combine, the more the X-Factor and
interest, by extension, is multiplied.
And so, here's kind of like a level of
thinking, levels of X Factor. So if you
have an a sea of average people, if you
have a hot small blonde, all of a sudden
that is rarer. And so there's a little
bit of X Factors. Are there a lot? No,
but there's more than none. Now let's
say that this small blonde has big
boobs. Okay, that's rarer than just
small hot blonde. Who then also grew up
in deep poverty. Huh, that's a little
bit different. Even rarer.
But now she's really smart. That's even
rarer. Uh and also can sing amazingly
well. And can write really emotional
songs.
And is incredibly self-aware and wise.
And also a business tycoon.
And also extremely feminine while being
a business tycoon. And also has no
scandals whatsoever for the entirety of
her life. And has incredibly strong
stances but is beloved by black people,
white people, old people, young people,
Republicans and Democrats.
Is deeply kind. Is married for 50 plus
years and never shows her husband
publicly.
And hit had a hit every single decade
for 60 years.
Hit the charts. And is humble. And
whenever she's given uh you know
flowers, she constantly deflects with
jokes and credits God and good luck.
And so obviously when you take all those
things together, that's a hell of a lot
of X Factor. And that gives you none
other than the great Dolly Parton.
There's literally no other human being
on Earth who satisfies that criteria,
which makes her incredibly rare.
And so what makes them so strong
specifically for her is how many of them
are both rare and also, this is the key
point, contradictory. She's sexy but
also saintly. She's a hillbilly but
she's also a business mogul. She's a
bombshell but she's also a songwriter.
She's old but she's relevant. She's a
superstar and she's humble. Right? All
of these are what would appear to be
contradictions but they're both uh
they're all in the same person, which
makes her rare and interesting.
And so, each of these are rare in their
own. They're rarer when someone has
multiple of them. Like, if someone's
just a sexy hillbilly, that's rare. A
bombshell, uh, and old, and a superstar.
Like, each of these adds on top of one
another.
But, they're rarest when they coexist
all together.
And she managed to do all this while
staying likable because she never got
mixed in politics, and she stayed
relatable. So, both those things, like,
in terms of Alex's notes, those are
notes that I have. And just for God's
sakes, like, to to prove this point, her
number one song of all time is her
begging another woman not to steal her
man. Think about crazy this is. You've
got this
smoking hot bombshell, sweet, epitome of
femininity, class, right? Um,
who's wealthy beyond means and a
superstar, her main song is the most
humbling version of this. It's not like,
"I'm so hot," right? From Mims, or "This
is why I'm hot," right? By Mims. Uh, but
instead, is Jolene, about a bank teller
that she knew had a crush on her
husband, and she was begging her not to
steal her man. Like, how how much more
relatable could you be, right? And so,
that is why Dolly is not just a star,
but a superstar.
And so, I'm making this because I
generally believe that there's many more
stars and superstars who are out there
that simply haven't recognized it in
themselves. And so, the reason they
aren't is because people take their
personalities off the shelf. They take
them stock. They take the default
option. And so, I I I put this meme
together that I remember seeing
somewhere or some version of this, but
it's like, white men turning 30, and
they're trying to pick between grilling
meat or craft beer as their new hobby,
right? And so, it's like, people just
stay incredibly confined in these boxes
because they think it's the only
acceptable option socially for them.
But, that makes them just like everyone
else. And yes, you will fit in, but you
will never be exceptional. And so, I
want you to think I want you to do this
exercise with me. So, imagine a guy
wearing a trucker hat, uh, wearing a
flannel. Okay? Just think about that
guy. I have an image of just like a
stereotypical guy. All right? Now,
you don't know anything about this guy.
But,
what are this guy's political views?
What does he drive? What do you think he
drives? If you look at this guy, if you
had to make a bet, what do you think he
drives?
What do you think his religion is if you
had to guess?
How do you think he likes his coffee?
Do you think he's a vegan?
What do you think his hobbies are or
skills are?
You probably, looking at this, could
make some pretty decent bets.
And before you even talk to this person,
you have an idea of who they're going to
be.
And even more, you'll have an idea of
whether or not you're going to like
them.
And you can fill in the rest of the
details about this person and probably
be mostly right most of the time.
And how is that possible? Because of
pattern recognition. Most people who
dress this way act this way. And that is
by nature judging a book by its cover.
And I want to be very clear, this will
never stop. We can be as woke as we want
as a culture, people are never going to
stop judging a book by its cover because
it's asking humans not to make
predictive judgments, right? It's acting
asking human to stop recognizing
patterns. Of course, it's going to
happen. It's how we think. It's how we
manage our way through the world.
So, in leveraging this innate human
trait that we will not be able to
change, how do you become interesting
and eventually have X factor and then
eventually become a superstar?
You have to break the pattern. You have
to be what they don't expect or they
don't predict. So, if that guy, if I
said, "Hey, this guy drives a Tesla."
And he's actually an atheist and he
likes Frappuccinos not black coffee,
which is probably what you would have
guessed. And he actually is a vegan,
right? And he's a world-class computer
hacker. That all of a sudden makes this
person way more interesting or different
than you probably would have expected.
And maybe he's a violinist. Huh? These
things don't go together. And so, that
makes him more interesting cuz most
likely, he was able to think for
himself, have high agency, and as a
result, make his own decisions about the
world rather than just saying, "I guess
I'm 30 and I'm a white guy. I got to go
craft beers or grilling meats. Which
Which am I going to pick?" Right? Cuz he
actually decided to think for himself.
Maybe I don't want any of those things.
And the degree to which you break the
pattern, you'll garner general
attention. And degree to which you break
it and then they like the way that you
broke it, you'll get positive attention.
And so you need to learn to fully lean
into and embrace the parts of you that
make you different. And these are
typically the parts of you that you hide
for fear of judgment and mockery. And
these are also the parts of you that
other people don't often like or they
think are weird or cringe or just
doesn't fit in with the pack, which
makes sense because how can you become
exceptional without being different?
Right? And sometimes these are things
you don't like about yourself.
But that's okay.
And so for example,
by different people throughout my
career, I was told adamantly, I want to
tell you four things that I was told
adamantly throughout my career. Number
one, don't try doing YouTube or getting
on camera. It's really hard and you're
probably not going to do well with it.
This is what I was literally told, don't
do it.
Number two, they told me to wear a suit
in order to be taken seriously in
business. This was like one of the first
piece of advice I had and you can still
see I think on my Facebook I still kept
the picture of me in a suit and I I put
this suit on cuz I thought that that's
what I needed to do.
Um do not talk about your philosophy on
life because no one cares. This was
something that I was told kind of on my
way up uh in terms of like content
buckets and I was like I kind of talk
about this stuff even though it didn't
really have anything to do with
business. Um but it's now probably one
of the number one things that people
stop me in the street and they're like,
"No, I love the business stuff but when
you kind of sprinkle in some of the life
pieces, like those are the things that
actually helped me the most." Um don't
talk about how much money you make
because it's really cringe.
I I talk about money. It's just part of
who I am. Right? And it took me some
time to get over these things but I
ended up going against all of this
because it didn't feel natural to who I
am. Right? And I think about life every
day and I I think about those things. I
think about money and I talk about money
openly. Um I wear what I want to wear. I
want to wear what I'm comfortable with.
And that'll change when I want it to
change. And I think the meta is just
like being you. Right? And to be clear,
I'm not saying that I'm a superstar.
Dolly is in a league of her own. I'm
saying that this is an observation and
applying it to myself because I've
garnered above average interest and I'm
saying to help. And so there are parts
of yourself that make you different and
they make you an exception. They allow
you to break the pattern. And the more
different and rare they are, the more
exceptional they are. And the more of
the pattern they break.
And so, I believe the reason people say
X factor and je ne sais quoi is because
of the truth of each of these statements
have embedded inside of them.
And so, je ne sais quoi is I don't know
what because no single what is what
makes someone exceptional, right? It's
not just being blonde or having big
boobs or being humble or being good at
business or being a good singer, right?
If someone just has big boobs, are they
exceptional? Not really, right? What
about just being humble? Is that
exceptional? Not really. Just being good
at business? Not really, right?
Does that make you a star? No.
And that's why it's difficult to put
this into words because when you name
one of them, it doesn't seem
extraordinary at all. It actually seems
almost ordinary.
It's having them all, aka the full
package.
And the second, like I said, so that's
the je ne sais quoi, that's the what.
The second is the X factor, which is the
English version of this. And I think
about this is like X marks the spot,
right? And so, it's the cross-section of
all these things where stardom lives,
right? You got singer, classy, bimbo,
smart, business mogul. The
cross-section, like what's the Venn
diagram, the intersection of all those
points is one person. That is the X
factor.
And I think that that's something that
we can all take from Dolly and we can
apply to our own lives is to be
violently ourselves with all of our
idiosyncrasies, our quirks, the atypical
ways that we have of behaving, accept
them as obviously different, but in so
doing make us exceptional.
And to be clear, I don't want to end
this with a be yourself takeaway. If
Dolly couldn't sing or write hell of a
good songs like she did, she wouldn't
have been a star. You have to be really
[__] good, period. End of state like
end of statement.
But, there are a lot of really [__]
good people who aren't stars or don't
stick. And that is because number one,
they're good, but they're not great.
They're not really [__] great. Or
number two, even if they are, they have
nothing else.
And so, just like the French saying je
ne sais quoi,
it's not about having one thing.
It's about having everything. It's about
having the full package. And that is
what X Factor is all about. And that's
how you stand out in a world that wants
to blend in is be really [__] good
and be fully you and embrace the
components of yourself that don't
necessarily belong together. You want to
You want to have the pieces of yourself
that are
I think about death in a weird way. I'm
also kind of good at violin. I also kind
of like public speaking and I do some
coding. Like why do you think Joe Rogan
can talk about UFC you know fighting and
comedy and biohacking and politics and
aliens? Like all of these things don't
necessarily belong together, but the
only intersection of those points is
him, right? So like he has X Factor. He
has a star and typically all of that
comes from this level of agency of
self-acceptance, right? Is that she,
Dolly Parton, Joe Rogan are willing to
accept themselves as they were and just
say this is what I'm into. And by doing
that people
either admire that level of courage or
and or they see a part of themselves in
you because the more diverse the
different interests you have, the more
diverse of an audience you can also
merely attract, right? Because if you
are just the stock off the shelf, I
drink black coffee, I'm conservative, I
I wear flannels and a trucker hat and I
have a Christian worldview
etc. etc. right? Like right off the
shelf. And again, I'm not saying there's
nothing wrong with that. I'm just saying
it's common.
The likelihood that you have to be able
to put other things in that bucket.
What's the something you know something
spice and everything nice or whatever
the the little child saying is.
You have to have X Factor which means
that usually there's parts of you and
this is why I believe this genuinely is
that people all have unique elements of
themselves that are more unique, but
because they're afraid of judgment,
they're unwilling to share them because
they want to be included in the group,
which makes sense evolutionarily, but
not in terms of achieving kind of
exceptionalism. And to be clear, I'm not
saying that being exceptional is the
goal.
You know, you can choose whether you
want to be happy or you want to be
special. Like those are not necessarily
always the same thing. They're different
goals. Sometimes they they can't
overlap. I think Dolly was both.
Um,
but they are different objectives. And
so I have a huge amount of respect for
Dolly Parton. I was looking at all of
her stuff um
in the wake of her death obviously. And
so uh that is why I'm dedicating this to
to Dolly. RIP. May we all be more like
you.